could you explain which is the night of
decree or the night of power as far as
the
exact date or day of the night of power
according to S bukari the commentary of
sari fat it says that there are more
than 40 different versions which the
scholars have given regarding the day or
the date of the night of power some say
it's the first night of the month of
Ramadan some say it's the seventh night
some say it's the 19th night they
different versions but the most
authentic according to the say had is
that it is one of the odd nights in the
last 10 nights of the month of Ramadan
and it's mentioned
in s bukari volume number three in the
book of
superiority of the night of khad Hadith
number
2017 Allah's messenger Muhammad
sallallah Al wasallam
said that seek for the night of in the
odd nights amongst the last 10 days of
Ramadan so this is the most
authentic and further it's mentioned in
s bukari volume number one in the book
of Faith Hadith number 49 Allah's
messenger Muhammad sallallah Ali
wasallam said that he once went out to
tell the Muslims the exact date of the
night ofad then he saw that two Muslim
men they were fighting amongst
themselves they were quing and he said
that so and so and so and so amongst the
Muslim men they were quing and Allah
subhana tala took away the knowledge
that means he forgot it and the prophet
said maybe it's better for the Muslims
so seek for the on the
7th or the 9th or the fifth night
amongst the last 10 nights of Ramadan so
here the option given by Allah's
messenger
for and further it's mentioned
in s Muslim volume number two in the
book of fasting Hadith number
2364 with him he said by Allah he heard
sha saying that most probably the night
of Kad
is on the 27th night because the prophet
peace be upon him he asked us to stand
up in prayer in this night so according
to this Hadith most probably is the
27th night of Ramadan further it's
mentioned in in that the Beloved Prophet
M wasallam said that seek for the night
of on the 21st night 23rd night 25th
night on the 27th night and the last
night in the month of Ramadan it's
mentioned in s bukari number three in
the book of Hadith number
2020 that the Beloved prophet he used to
do in the last 10 days of Ramadan and
he's to seek for the in the last 10
nights of
Ramadan it further mentioned in say
Muslim volume number two in the book of
fasting
Hadith
number
that Prophet wasallam said that seek for
the night of in the last 10 nights but
if you're
weak and if you cannot do in the early
parts of the month of Ramadan then seek
it in the last seven nights of Ramadan
it's further mentioned
inkari volume number three in the book
of superiority of Hadith number
2015 Prophet Mall Al wasallam
said that the night of khadr is during
the last seven nights of the month of
Ramadan so from VAR record you come to
know
that is most
probably in the last 10 nights of
Ramadan that's the reason most of the
scholars including
sh Bas most of the scholar they say that
no one knows when is the exact date of
when is the exact day of the night of
decree
but it is in the month of Ramadan and
most probably in the last 10 nights of
the month of Ramadan and most probably
in the odd nights of the last 10 nights
of the month of Ramadan most probably on
the 27th night but no one can pinpoint
the exact date but surely inshallah it's
in the last 10 nights of Ramadan most
probably in the odd nights in the last
10 nights of Ramadan this is what the
most of the scholars say well may we
find that night inshallah